- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to think about
how trade can alter the equilibrium
price and quantity in a given market.
So what we see here, as we like to do,
are very simplified examples of markets
in various economies.
So first, we have country A,
and let's say it's the market for widgets.
And we're going to assume that country A
is not trading with anyone else.
So it is an autarky, a very
fancy word, which just means
that this country is
operating independently.
It's operating in isolation.
And so you can see the demand curve
in this market in orange,
and we can see the supply curve.
And you can see,
when this country is
operating in isolation,
this market for widgets
has an equilibrium price.
It looks like it's a little bit under $4.
I'll just assume that the
price is in dollars per widget.
And the equilibrium quantity
looks like it's about a
little under four units
per whatever time period we're looking at.
Fair enough.
Now let's look at country B,
and let's assume that they are
also operating independently.
It's an autarky in this market.
And so here, we can see a different
demand curve than what we saw in country A
and a different supply curve.
And notice they have a different
equilibrium price and quantity.
So here, the equilibrium price
seems to be a little bit over $1,
and the equilibrium quantity
seems to actually be
not that different than what
we saw in the first country.
Although, in many situations,
it could be very different.
Now let's imagine what would happen
if they opened up their
economies to each other.
Well, then you would essentially
horizontally add these two demand curves,
and you would horizontally
add these two supply curves
to come up with a new supply curve
and a new demand curve. This
is a little bit of a review
of what we've seen in other videos.
But notice, at a price of five,
in total, no one's demanding anything,
no quantity of these widgets.
And then at a price of zero,
country A, the market
there is demanding 15,
and country B is demanding five.
So in aggregate, they're demanding 20.
And similarly, you can
see that with supply,
that at a price of five,
country A will supply five.
And at a price of five,
country B will supply 15.
And so together, they will
supply 20 units per time period.
And so we can view this right over here
as our supply and demand curves
for the combined markets
because now they're trading.
We are not in an autarky anymore.
And notice what has happened.
Our equilibrium price is now someplace
in between these two equilibrium prices.
So it looks like it's
a little bit under $3.
And our equilibrium quantity,
our equilibrium quantity is
a little bit under 10 units.
And so you might notice
some interesting things
that are happening.
What would happen from a,
someone in country A's point of view,
the people who are the buyers,
the people who are demanding this widget?
Well, now, instead of
having to pay almost four,
they're paying someplace
in between two and three.
This is the new equilibrium price
if they were to open up their economy.
And so what you have is, is that this,
this amount would be produced by,
in theory, by the domestic manufacturers,
so the first, let's call that 2 1/2 units.
And then the remainder,
where are they going to
get those units from?
Well, those are going to be imports.
And let's look at the
equilibrium price on country B,
and country B was really
the lower cost producer.
And so country B, now we have a,
let's put it a little bit over 2.5,
so let's put it right over there.
And so now you have a
situation where the suppliers
in country B are going
to be producing a lot,
a lot more than they were before.
And only this amount is coming
from their domestic demand.
And then all of this
amount right over here,
that is being exported.
And if we're assuming
that the world economy
is only made up of country A and country B
or that they're only
trading with each other,
these exports become country A's
imports right over there.
And so proponents of free
trade will say, hey, look,
the overall consumer surplus is larger
than the combined consumer
surpluses that we had before.
Before, you had this consumer
surplus in country A.
And country B,
it was all of this.
But still, this entire area is larger
than these two combined.
And you could do it
mathematically if you like,
calculate the area of these triangles.
And if you look at the producer surplus,
you'll see a similar story.
The total producer surplus of
the combined economies now,
this is going to be larger
than this producer surplus
plus this producer surplus.
Now, some,
there will not always be winners in this.
The winners here are the
demanders in country A.
Because instead of this
little, small consumer surplus
that they had before, now
they have this much larger
consumer surplus right over there.
And then the other winners are
the suppliers in country B.
'Cause instead of this producer surplus
that they had before,
they now have this producer surplus.
But the losers in this situation
are the suppliers in country A
who now have a much
lower producer surplus.
So their triangle has shrunk
to that right over there.
And then the other
losers in this situation
are the consumers in country B
who now have to pay a
higher equilibrium price.
And so their consumer surplus
is only this small triangle,
when before it was this whole thing.
So anyway, the big takeaway here is,
is that if you go from autarky
to opening up economies,
it can affect what the equilibrium
prices and quantities are going to be.
And oftentimes or usually,
it's going to increase
your total consumer and producer surplus.
Although, there will be some winners,
and there will be some losers.